hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on done appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become hi I'm Joanna sue and welcome
to another cardio workout I'm really
excited because this is an animal flow
inspired workout so we want to move like
an animal and we want to move in all
directions to the front to the back to
the sides basically just let your body
flow okay and this workout it's a really
good sculpting and toning workout as
well as coordination workout right
so get your animal spirit on and let's
do this let's start with a really simple
warmup inchworm so step right at the
edge of your mat and slowly inch forward
keeping your leg straight I want you to
just stretch forward and slowly stretch
back keeping your legs and your
hamstring straight so you should feel
the stretch on your hamstrings good
reach as far as you can into a high
plank and slowly change back nice
who loves animal flow workout if you
have not done it well this is a really
good workout to start off with and
slowly go back and come back up and one
last one as you reach forward I want to
just stay here and get into walking dog
so just Pike your butt up and just walk
it out okay so bring your left heel down
alternating with your right heel keep
walking and feel the stretch on your
calves good we want to just loosen up
the muscles and get them ready for your
cardio workout so this is a
high-intensity 20 minutes cardio workout
so we want to get those muscles ready
alright few more stretch it up and just
bring both heels down and just stretch
out Pike your butt up point it up and
I'll just bring your right hand forward
and then open up to one side bring it
back left on forward stretch it up open
it up bring it back again right
open up stretch up bring it back left
open up and slowly bring it back and
slowly come up all right
okay all the workouts are named based on
an animal movement okay so the first
workout is a duck walk so if you have
seen the Wade duck walk they basically
stay really low okay I went to maintain
a really low position and just slowly
inch forward okay so left and right left
and right staying low if you have a net
use that net as your guideline if you
want to go outdoor get get to the park
and do this workout you can do that as
well okay if you have a bigger space
then by all means walk further
all right so stay low 30 seconds work 15
seconds rest okay now turn around
keep walking slowly bring your left leg
and your right leg and turn around
keeping your arms up okay keep your butt
low and slowly turn around so walk
forward like a duck and turn around good
stay low alright and this will also work
on your legs and now come back up okay
shake it out a little bit bad crawl so
we want to get onto all fours all right
so start at the edge of your mat if you
can to get onto all fours lift your
knees slightly off the floor and slowly
climb and crawl forward okay keeping
your back flat and then reverse that's
it
do not Pike your butt up okay keep your
butt low stay low back flat and slowly
crawl forward as you reach the edge of
the mat call back again if you have a
bigger space remember you can
crawl further keep going through the
burn on your legs
whew your upper body working as well and
now stand up good so we've worked on the
front side let's get on to crap walk
so now stop again at the edge of your
mat okay get into sort of like a reverse
plank position lift your butt up I want
you to slowly inch forward okay so inch
forward on your heels right at the end
you will feel the work on your triceps
ever sorrell and slowly inch back whoa
there you go lift your butt up slowly
walk forward like a Crabby to the edge
and now walk back on your heels and
forward nice and slowly stand up okay
kangaroo hops all right so what I want
to do again start at the edge of your
mat okay so get into a deep white and no
squat tap onto the map hop forward reach
hop forward reach hop forward and reach
and turn around again hop forward reach
push back reach hop forward and reach
Center and if you have a bigger face you
will be able to hop for that if not take
three hops stand up turn around
tap look straight ahead chest up tap to
the road last one more hop hop and stand
back up alright good lateral eight so
now we want to work on the left and
right direction okay again start at the
edge of your mat okay so hands down what
I want to do is hop to the side so move
your body with the hands to the side let
your hands guide you okay let your hands
lead you to the side and now release
move it move
release and move on to the left side
release it and go on to your right
whoa I can feel my thighs burning
release once more and come back up shake
it out a little bit frog jumps okay with
frog jumps just stay on your mat all you
have to do is get into a high plank and
hop both legs in okay so high plank hop
your legs in hop out
hop in and hop out okay good that's it
so it's an easy workout but it would
drive your heart rate up okay if you
want to you can even release your hands
and get into a deep squat position
release your hands good so choose your
option okay release hop up hop in
release hop out and in and release and
not slowly stand back up let's get into
half scorpion right with half scorpion
again get into a high plane this will
work on your coordination and your
mobility what I want to do is release
your left leg twist the opposite side
open high plank relief twist and open
okay so it will work on your hips
mobility as well as your lower back
alright just half scorpion so open up
look straight up palms up back it to
high plank and back down okay find your
balance work on the core and rest it out
good job that was a round one you might
feel that you're a little bit clumsy
trying to find and get the movements
right but that is okay okay
second round let's do all the exercises
again and let's make the movement flow
better so grab some water
give yourself hydrated what they sweat
and wrong to you
what okay
all right 15 seconds left okay so the
first will be a walk all right so
remember stay low you can use the mat as
your guide if you have a small space use
the mat let's go okay
just like a duck slowly turn around stay
low and go move your hips side to side
and stay low and let's go nice turn
around chest up
okay push it through your glutes turn
around one last one
all right now let's go on with bear
crawl so get onto all fours okay get
onto all fours lift your heels off lift
your knees off slightly
and now let's slowly crawl forward
keeping your back flat okay and crawl
back good
slowly go forward stay low
and now back forward bringing your knee
to your elbow and crawl back good keep
going and relax all right now let's go
reverse so you have done bad crawl now
let's go with crap walk ok so lift your
body up we want to go reverse and then
crawl forward ok ready
let's go heels off crawl forward leave
your butt as high as you can
alright good and now forward slowly inch
forward push your part up and crawl back
if you find that you're struggling
because of a coordination that's ok take
it one step at a time
engage your muscles it takes time you
know sometimes for your body to know
what on earth are you trying to do so
slowly crawl forward and now come up
right kangaroo hops let's start at the
edge of your mat ok so stay in a low
deep squat all right three seconds left
catch your breath let's go low a top
power three hops small hops if you want
to you can even burst to a far hop okay
and that's in a rock down first
what burst good turn around down
turn around last hop and just press it
out all right
right now let's work on lateral okay
just gotta tie my shoelace really
quickly let's work on the left and right
side so start at the edge of your mat
okay let your hands guide you hop hop
and hop good again with your arms good
hop hop and hop
stay low to the side and you walk
through the work on your outer thighs
stay low if you want to stand up a
little bit take your butt up okay and
push it ha my legs are absolutely
burning let me know if your legs are
burning as well in the comments below
okay alright good now let's get down
onto the neck for frog jumps okay let's
choose to release your hand so start in
the high plank jump release jump back
jump and release okay burst into the
move jump up release jump up and release
good beginners if this is too tough take
a step back take a step forward and
release down
step back step forward and release okay
if not burst birth and up okay half
scorpion are you ready for this all
right let's see your move okay so start
in a high plank right and ready let's
start on your left side and let's go
open up rotate open up rotate
and good rotate open up the hips point
them up towards the ceiling
put your hips up and open up your back
squeeze your back as well
back down last worked out and you would
get a short break
look at one direction and down alright
stand back up
breathe that was two rounds you should
already get used to the movement for the
final roll I want you to push yourself
give me your best effort okay take a
short break about 30 seconds left
okay 15 seconds left we're gonna start
with duck walk your heart rate should be
high up you should be sweaty your legs
should be burning and you should feel
your entire body working okay let's not
stop right now let's start at the edge
of your mat let's go walk like a duck
show me your best dog walk slowly turn
around stay low and walk forward all
right nice turn around stay low walk
forward good turn around
huh come on once more okay turn around
walk forward all right now
bear crawl let's start at the edge of
your mat okay so again get onto all
fours you just adjust my Mike get into
all fours
lift off your heels your knees and bring
your knee close to your elbow while
maintaining a flat back and keeping your
body low look it down look at the floor
crawl back crawl forward keeping your
knees as close to the floor as possible
few more and rest it off okay are we
ready for crab walk again let's go into
a reverse plank position bend your knees
get onto your heels point your fingers
forward okay lift your bum off and let's
go let's inch forward pushing your butt
up as far as you can and go back
good forward and go back for some of you
you might struggle because you might
find that your upper body is weak so
it's a good it's a good way to know what
part to work more on okay so slowly
leave your pot up do not drop it back
and rest it out okay
kangaroo house this is a killer man if
you have a big space I challenge you to
take wider hops forward okay so start
low all right deep squat ready let's go
hop hop
sighs okay as far as you can hop turn
around as high and as far as you can
okay turn around turn
let's go keep going sit around and come
back okay
lap show a bouquet so if you want to
hike your butt up let your hands leave
you okay so start high up pack your butt
up all right
hence leaving you hop arms pop and hop
release let's go
release release good there you go you
got it up to you more you have 10
seconds left up last one more round and
slowly come up
oh this is not easy it's a really good
cardio workout frog jumps okay so let's
start in a high plank position last two
exercises and you are done
choose your option okay so start a high
plank hop forward release hop back hop
forward or choose to step in and out out
in
like a froggy okay let's speed it up
there you go let's spit it up laughs
around let's go give me three more
that's two that's one more huh stand
back up shake it out a little bit you
have one final workout half scorpion
okay so start in a high plank
all right remember your goal is to point
your hips your entire body up so let's
go open up rotate open and rotate
breathe less than 20 seconds
pushup
few more work those flexibility and rest
it out okay
no just everything bring your heart rate
down and let's get into a cobra do with
how anyone flow let's push up bra
breathe slow daya breathing you are not
rushing in America roll your shoulders
push higher up
and now release get onto your toes into
downward dogs okay so let's start with
walking dog alternating between left and
right and now just slowly bring that to
a stop pointing both heels down push
back pack your butt up
feel the stretch on your back as well as
your calves
alright ok enough slowly just come down
into a child's pose just know everybody
if you can try to reach forward and feel
your back being stretched out
[Music]
and not a little rotation just reach
your right arm under and across and just
twist you will feel more stretch on your
right back
release change left under
and now slowly come up put yourself up I
want you to take three deep breaths okay
so legs slightly wider than
shoulder-width apart
breathe in reach up and release laughs
ah again breathe in loud okay go really
loud and release all the bad energy
inhaling all the good energy once more
release alright guys
very well done if this is your first
animal flow workout well you have worked
on your strength your coordination your
flexibility as well as your agility be
sure to fit in this workout into your
routine at least two to three times
weekly okay and you can mix it up with
other strength training workout if you
want more of this type of workout let me
know in the comments below give this
video a thumbs up and be sure to
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more workout videos workout
challenges healthy meal plans as well as
nutritional tips and don't forget to
check out my fitness app called a few on
the App Store or the Play Store where
I'll be sharing daily classes so be sure
to check it out and I will see you in my
next video all the best